I didn't know how much I could love, actually love, till I met you.
I've never wanted anything more than for you to be my wife.
This is all I want on my wedding day.
Sol?
Hey, if we get bad news, we should get a dog.
Don't say that.
We're getting good news.
He's ours.
They found cancer, and it's spread.
We don't have much time left.
We knew that this was gonna be hard.
I am in this with you.
I can't do this to you.
You don't get to choose when I tap out.
Do I get to choose?
Not alone, not anymore.
This is gonna be the happiest day of our lives.
Thank you for showing me what living is, what home is.
You make me feel like I can do anything.
We can do anything.
So, one out of five chance that I don't see you next year?
Four out of five, you do.
Every morning, I wake up and I choose you.
I choose us.